the jurgen experience what made you
decide to write about comfort isn't
comfort a good thing michael
what is going on well you have a problem
with comfort the comfort crisis is it
really a crisis
i argue that it is a crisis one i don't
have a problem with
comfort uh i do have a problem with
always being comfortable always leaning
into comfort which is what we're doing
now
yeah right so if you think of the
average person's daily life
they wake up in the soft bed temperature
controlled home
they shuffle over to the microwave
microwave a breakfast burrito right that
came in from who knows where and is made
with who knows what and then it's like
i go to work i drive to work i sit
behind this screen all day
i don't have to move at all or put any
effort into this day and then it's
back to bed in front of the tv and you
just rinse and repeat that
at no point in daily life i would argue
are people really challenged or really
uncomfortable anymore like we were in
our past
some people of course sound right
there's david goggins is still alive and
well
yes david goggins is running right now
and so he's like the type of person you
see what happens when you start to push
against that right when you kind of have
this moment where you go
maybe i'm a little too comfortable and
you start to sort of investigate okay
what is it with discomfort
how can i get into some discomfort and
what can that do for me
and then at the extreme end of that is
is goggins
yeah well
it's for folks that just like say if you
work in an office
and this is how you make a living and
you have to do that commute and there's
no other options and this is what you do
like for them to hear this they're like
yeah yeah
okay so what what what now well
i mean the answer is not to totally
overhaul your lifestyle right i mean we
have
amazing lives right now the fact that we
don't have to go out and
hunt for food or put physical effort
into every day
is great but at the same time i think
and i argue in the book
the comfort crisis that we need these
moments that push back at us and we need
to
sort of investigate these discomforts
that we used to face
in our evolutionary past so for example
two that's the percent of people who
take the stairs when there's the choice
two percent
two percent people who take the stairs
when there's a choice of an escalator
seventy percent of people more than
seventy percent now are overweight or
obese
twenty only twenty percent of hunger uh
sorry only twenty percent of eating is
actually driven by physiological hunger
eighty percent of it is just i'm bored
uh it's noon i guess i'll eat or i'm
stressed out
right we exercise more
we exercise 14 times less than our
ancestors nowadays
so our ancestors just just by virtue of
trying to
survive you mean yeah exactly so they
didn't exercise right
like our hunter gatherer yeah they never
did chin ups exactly that was life to
them yeah yeah
we're trying to get by yeah and we spend
95 of our time indoors as well
and we know that there's benefits to
getting out and moving more we know
there's benefits to being outside
we also know that there's benefits to
truly being challenged in life
it's like like i said before you can
basically
never be challenged as you go through
life in a real sort of fundamental way
and you'll probably have a decent life
but you know if you think about
potential and human potential let's say
that human potential is this big circle
around us right now most of us live in
this sort of dinner plate
sized place we never go out and explore
the edges of our potential
by trying to get uncomfortable and doing
things that are maybe a little outside
of our comfort zone we can just kind of
exist in this sort of
soft space that we've created for
ourselves right now and of course there
are people who get out and
you know into that those edges like
like the goggins of the world like the
campaigns of the world
uh but i think most people don't really
go out and see what they're capable of
no i don't think anybody's going to push
back against this book
you know no i don't which brings it
creates a kind of a dilemma for you is
there comfort in just writing about
discomfort
right is there a debate here because i
don't think there is i mean i think what
you're saying is like
irrefutable i don't i don't think
anybody can say well there's nothing
wrong with being sedentary and having
your body turn into jello
well there's nothing wrong with living a
boring life with no stress at all and
and well stressed but mental stress no
no actual
physical adversity to overcome which
stresses out the body but actually
relaxes the mind which is
which is that's the that's what people
are missing right that's the
the when you actually physically exert
yourself it actually
calms the mind and i think there's
probably direct correlation although i
haven't done any studies
i would imagine there's a direct
correlation between physical inactivity
and mental depression i would i would
have to imagine that
there's at least some crossover there
yeah there absolutely is
uh i think that exercise the studies
show they grow the it grows the
hippocampus which is an area that tends
to be shrunken in people who have
depression
so this is why the apa now advocates
that
psychiatrists recommend exercise to a
lot of their patients
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only
on spotify watch back catalog jre videos
on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience